did the duopoly it's a two-party system
that that pretends to be fighting each
other most of the time sometimes they
really do fight but most of the times
it's all pretend it's all WWE it's all
entertainment it's all Showmanship but
that feels a little archaic to me I mean
I I agree mostly but since Donald Trump
got into office we started seeing a
whole bunch of libertarian and America
First candidates I'm not saying they
overlap they're they're both
anti-establishment factions the house
Freedom caucus where Ron DeSantis I
believe he helped found it has been
pushing back and expanding within their
within the Republican party so that's
what I'm looking at obviously I'm not
excited for Mitch McConnell no one likes
this guy this is the funny thing I
pulled up the Civics polls and went
through every single demographic not a
single demographic views him favorably
not even Republicans
how's this guy leading the charge
because there's because there's they're
all cowards exactly there's a reason FTX
was donating not only overwhelmingly to
Democrats but also to the GOP